We're going to look at the testing a couple of bitwise functions.
What we're going to want to do is write two Python functions called
high common bits and low common bits.
Given two inputs (a) and (b) which are integers that have the same size, let's say 32 or 64 bit integers.
Return integer with the same bit width with the higher the bits
that the two inputs have in common are included in the return value.
The first bit where the two inputs differ at a bit position
starting from the high end is set and all remaining bits are cleared.
Okay, so that's probably completely unclear.
This is the list of requirements, so we're going to do an example.
If (a) is 10101 and (b) is 10011, then the output is going to be
the higher bits that they have in common.
The 1 is common in sudden both inputs, so we return that.
Zero is in common, so we've copy that to the output.
This bit is different. The third bit is different so we want to set that bit and clear all remaining bits.
Hopefully, that's good. So we copied bits that are in common until we find a difference.
We set that bit and everything else is clear.
We also want to implement a function called low common bits,
that does the same thing except starting from the bottom end.
We take the same example and we do the low common bits.
Let's start at the bottom and see that 1 is common, so we copy it between the two.
The next bit, the second bit from the bottom, is different so we set that bit and clear all the rest.
And so what you might be saying to yourself at this point is, this functions look really silly.
But this look like a contrived example that a professor would come up with
just to mess with the students but does not actually the case.
It's functions come from an optimized trie implementation.
What a trie is, it's a kind of a balanced ordered tree, not incredibly unlike the splay tree
that we already looked at and some of it's branch,
but tries rely on bitwise operations to find the descendants of nodes
in order to get really high performance and really low-memory footprints.